welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and werewolf finite has introduced man
thing to the MCU in the most menacingly
adorable fashion but as a lot of MCU
fans know werewolf by night was not the
first time man thing has appeared in the
MCU because the Grand Master from Thor
Ragnarok is also no stranger to the man
thing as man thing's face can be seen
carved on the outside of the
grandmaster's palace alongside some of
sakar's greatest Champions so naturally
a big question a lot of MCU fans have
been wondering is uh how the hell did
the swamp ass Teddy get his ass into
orbit to even get to the planet of
soccer in the first place well let's
speculate all this together my
speculation Nation bear babies because I
think that there are a few possible ways
this could have happened but first do
not forget to hit up new
rockstarsverse.com so you can pick up
our latest Obsession shirts inspired by
both chihulk and House of the Dragon
like I always say they're not gonna last
forever so pick them up today so you can
wear cool shirts tomorrow alright so how
could the man think human object native
to the planet Earth find his way onto a
secluded Planet light years away from
his own solar system well I think one of
the biggest and most likely ways that
this could have happened could be due to
a past Cosmic event that has drastically
affected the entire Marvel Universe
simultaneously a little something called
the convergence as very skillfully
introduced and explained by a crazy Eric
Selvig in 2013's Thor the Dark World due
to this cosmic alignment of all the nine
Realms during the events of Floor 2
gravity on Earth was going haywire which
was causing random invisible portals to
form in a ton of different places around
the planet as well as nine massive
wormholes that opened up throughout each
major MCU realm it's basically how Jane
Foster was able to go from Earth to the
secret location of The Ether in a split
second and how Jane and Thor were able
to return to Earth from their isolation
on the dark elves Planet I believe that
there is a good chance that man thing
could have gone through one of these
portals and ended up on the planet of
sakar mainly because the planet of the
car itself is a massive unexplainable
gravitational nominal because I don't
know if you know this but there were so
many anuses surrounding the devil's anus
and Thor Ragnarok and each anus was
actually a wormhole that connected to a
different random area in the universe
which is why so many different types of
aliens were showing up on the planet of
sakhar but a major reason why I strongly
believe that man thing could have been
involved in this is because of a major
piece of Marvel terminology that appears
on Eric selvig's Blackboard when he is
explaining the convergence to his eager
audience in Thor 2 right here to be
exact the Nexus of all reality because
if you don't know man thing himself is
the protector of the Nexus of all
realities in the Marvel Comics as the
location of the doorway to the Nexus of
all realities is located within the
swamplands of the Florida Everglades and
was directly created the very moment
that Ted salus transformed into the man
thing when the demon magic chemicals of
his super soldier serum interacted with
the swamp it's a really long story Ted's
Al has made a deal with the devil and he
turned into the man thing it's weird
Just go with it I have a feeling that
because the Nexus of of all realities
can be accessed in the Florida swamps
that birth demand thing there was a good
chance that these swamps were covered in
wormholes that have the potential to
send people anywhere during the time of
the convergence and that one of these
wormholes LED man thing to being sent to
sakar by accident but that is just one
way because the other way man thing
could have gotten just a car is due to a
rotten white-haired man called The
Collector because in the Marvel Comics
The Collector and the Grand Master
consider themselves Brothers as they are
both impossibly old Elders of the
universe who like to kidnap people
against their will hooray and we learned
from Guardians of the Galaxy that the
collector has an impossibly massive
collection of unique aliens and items
from different planets this house the
Galaxy's largest collection a fauna
relics and species of all manner
so now that the collector himself has a
particular interest in big green
monsters as well as plant-based beings I
mean he literally offered to buy a
groot's body at the moment of his death
and just look at this weird greed
monstrosity sitting on the right over
here and since we do know that the
collector has a couple of items from
Earth like a whole ass Cosmo the space
dog it wouldn't be completely out of the
question to Guess that the collector
scooped up the man thing on a quick
visit to good old planet c53 and gave
man thing to his brother The Grandmaster
as a gift or a trade or something in
this visit to Earth could potentially
serve to explain why Howard the Duck is
in the collector's possession as well as
how are the doc actually made his first
Marvel comic appearances within the man
thing-centric stories of Avengers
interfere number 19 and man thing number
one when he comes across man thing in
the Nexus of all realities connected to
the swamps of Florida in the comics
Howard the Duck is not native to the 616
universe but instead got there via the
Nexus fall realities that connects all
universes so there is a possibility here
that the collector could have captured
both man thing and Howard to together at
the same time in Florida and lastly the
Third Way man thing could have made his
way just a car is by pure magic because
the big reason why man thing was even
referenced as a Coliseum fighter in Thor
Ragnarok is because man thing actually
fought in a Coliseum fight in the comics
because you see after being transported
to a far away distant planet by a tricky
wizard named dakim in the pages of
Adventures into fear number 14. man
thing was forced to fight in an alien
Coliseum to keep all the doors from the
Nexus of all realities from being opened
on earth a fight that man thing of
course would win with his super
convenient touch that burns anyone that
knows fear so since we do have a man
thing fighting in the grand Masters
Coliseum in the MCU we could be looking
at the handiwork of an MCU dakim or some
other evil sorcerer like Mordor or
something who could have needed the
Earth's Nexus protector out of the way
but yeah those are the three most likely
ways that I believe that man thing could
have arrived on sakar but what do you
guys think let us know in the comment
section below my nerd babies but thank
you guys so much for watching this video
you can follow me at mastertonment on
Twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] and really fun theories but
most importantly you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on the
internet and I'll see you guys next time
[Music]